throughout your career you've had all
kinds of different success and then now
with Barry last time around last year
you win the Emmy of your portrayal it's
so happy when you won the Emmy and I'm
curious you've been in the business a
long time to get jaded about that where
do you keep the Emmy do you just put it
in a closet where is it okay a people
always say you know I have it in the
bathroom yeah it's a doorstop yeah mine
is on the dining room table right now I
have been nominated many times before I
didn't get it I'm the I so I just
thought well maybe maybe not
it is a wonderful thing that I want and
the dining room table is opposite the
front door so that when somebody comes
and brings me my lipitor yeah bring it
I'm on lipitor there you get those three
you get three months batches at a time
it's true you're ordering them a day at
a time just so you can show the guy
every day your Emmy that's what you're
doing
well let's either that or the baby
aspirin but III and have deliveries yeah
just so I can open that door yeah I love
your presentation of your own a me to
anyone who comes by ah postmates swell
oh look what's over here you you're not
what did that cheeseburger just you're
you're up congratulations you're up
nominated again for an Emmy you're up
against two cast nights from Barry yes I
am do you feel conflicted about that you
know what may the best man win
if I lose to one of them I will totally
understand it be happy if I lose to the
other I will be so pissed off
[Laughter]